See,
one of the things that's happened
in Ontario recently is that we've,
our our government is introduced
legislation that is predicated on the
idea that all families are equal and the,
the idea behind that you
could argue is laudable.
I wouldn't argue that,
but you could argue it that you know,
people have a variety of ways of solving
the problem of having children and that
there's a variety of viable solutions
to that problem and that no one family
organizational type should be
privileged above the others.
I mean,
I suppose with the exception
of multipart in your marriages,
which we still don't approve of.
Let's say the problem with that as far
as I can tell is that it does appear from
the research that the nuclear
family is the smallest viable unit.
Which is not to say that there aren't
single mothers or single fathers who do an
admirable job under trying conditions.
But part of the problem,
this is a deep problem,
is that
whenever you,
whenever you pause it,
something as a value.
So you might say,
well,
we want intact families,
mother and father.
That's the.
That's the value we're heading for
because that seems to be best for the
children.
Then you produce a rank
order of accordance with that
and the people who aren't
in accordance with that value,
you can easily make a case that they're
being discriminated against and we're in
a situation in our society now where
even if the discrimination occurs,
let's say,
because of the pursuit
of an admirable value,
it's regarded as prejudicial and I
think that's fed by that underlying
hypothesis that was anti nuclear family,
that any sort of hierarchical structure
is part of the tear radical patriarchy.
It's something like that
that's running underneath it.
So anyways,
let's review if you would be very helpful.
I think for everyone,
some of the many ways that it's
necessary for children to have fathers,
why that's better and perhaps
also for for society as well,
not just for children.
Absolutely.
Children that have a lot about an equal
or more than equal father involvement
have a number of things in common as a
rule and obviously there's reversals of
this and not that everyone puts this,
this,
this pattern,
but the first is they're far more likely
to have postpone gratification and I'll
elaborate on that a little bit more.
Postpone gratification is probably the
single most important quality to becoming
successful and becoming successful,
especially being employed in a job that
has some meaning for you is one of the
most important ingredients in happiness
and a sense of purpose and a sense of
motivation and a sense of willingness
to get up in the morning and so I'm in a
little while.
I'll be happy to just trace back how
that postpone gratification happens more
when you have a father.
Yeah,
because I'm really interested
in hearing about that.
Second.
Second layer is far children and that
have an equal amount of father involvement
are far less likely to be depressed.
They're far less,
more likely to be assertive
and not aggressive,
which is something you usually
think of men as being aggressive,
but actually the children,
both girls and boys whose fathers are
involved are far more likely to understand
the distinction between being assertive
and being aggressive and choose
assertiveness.
Boys and another surprising one for me,
I'm doing the research was finding that
boys and girls who are raised with about
an equal amount of father involvement
are far more likely to be empathetic
because I always thought of empathy
coming predominantly from moms and I'll be
happy to explain in a bit why
it does come more from moms,
but why?
The outcome for the child
is not more empathy.
The outcome for the child is less empathy,
so a little bit more on that later.
Far more likely.
Both boys and girls should drop
out of school if there isn't far.
Father involvement.
A far more likely when a,
when a.
When a relationship breaks up,
a child that has not had significant
father involvement is much more likely to
be depressed and be withdrawn and b,
feel alienated.
I'm far more likely to be
addicted to video games,
far more likely to be
addicted to video porn.
I'm far less,
more likely to have a few social skills,
few emotional skills to do
worse in every academic area,
but especially in reading and writing,
which are the two biggest
predictors of success,
a far more likely to have
a lower sperm count have.
Um,
and here's an amazing thing.
I just discovered toward the end of the
research for the boy crisis I saw in
pediatrics magazine,
and that children who by the age of
nine don't have a significant amount of
father involvement in both girls and
boys who are likely to have shorter
telomeres.
And as most of us know,
the telomeres are pivotal in
predicting life expectancy.
So boys and girls,
the average shorter telomere for a nine
year old boy or girl without father
involvement was 14 percent a w,
I'm sorry,
it was a yes,
a 14 percent shorter,
but the boys,
telomeres were then again 40
percent shorter than the girls.
So here,
this was predicting about a 14 percent
shorter life expectancy for the average
child without father involvement
by the age of nine already.
And yet the boys were suffering more.
So two things fascinated me.
There is,
you know,
if all the things like,
dropping out of school
and things like that.
I asked myself,
well,
maybe this is because boys
with father involvement,
I'm just have better,
um,
better neighborhoods.
Um,
they,
the father's earned more,
the families are more,
maybe it's a matter of
poverty versus poverty.
So I started looking at a boys and
girls growing up in and good quote,
good neighborhoods with good schools
and comparing them with boys and girls
growing up in poor neighborhoods in
poor schools and found that the boys and
girls growing up in good neighborhoods
with poor schools that did not have
significant father involvement,
did about the same as boys and girls
growing up in poor neighborhoods with poor
schools that did have father involvement.
That father involvement was really as,
as good a predictor of success.
Um,
as the quality of the school system,
the quality of the neighborhood
and the socioeconomic class,
and this is what's led to,
you know,
to the psychologist I'm gathering
together behind people like worship 100
psychologists and researchers saying,
you know,
this is not a correlation.
The involvement of father,
this is not a matter of
socioeconomic issues.
This is a matter of actual father's,
father's,
father's involvement,
especially the biological father's
involvement actually makes a significant
difference.
We have been wrong about the assumption
that this would probably just a
correlation.
And so the more I looked,
the more I found just every
nightmare of a parent.
Um,
she'd be so increased,
uh,
when there was not a significant
amount of father involvement.
And I was seeing,
I was dating between,
before I married lives.
The woman you just met,
um,
just before we got on a,
before we got married 14 years ago,
um,
I was dating a number of women.
Almost every woman had a,
was a single mother and these,
every single woman was working
her rear end to balance her life.
Every woman used the word
overwhelmed by the way she felt.
Every.
Almost every woman said,
well,
I'd like my dad and the dad involved,
but um,
but when the.
But I started listening to the butts of
the women and then listening to men who
had,
wanted to be more involved with their
children and listening to what the
differences were between the mit,
what made the men feel not wanted,
what made the men feel excluded and why
the women felt that they needed to not
have the man involved.
And I saw this entire set
of misunderstandings here
and if I hope the boy crisis
does anything is so.
It's just sort of explained,
you know,
here are the 10 major
things that Dad's do that,
that sort of annoy women or make women
feel that they're not protecting their
children adequately.
Which when they understand the purpose
of these things and when dads get their
homework done enough to articulate to
the moms the purpose of these things that
will realize that the,
that the,
these are necessary
ingredients in a child's life.